bid admitted Friday that the border is
insecure does he have any plans to visit
the southern border one more let's go
back to this completely negligent Dei
filled ridiculous Administration here's
Karen jeanpierre one more time when
asking if old Joe could could we just
get that nice old man to show up to the
Border um Biden admitted Friday that the
border is insecure does he have any
plans to visit the southern border
before the election President wasn't
visited the Border recently in January
yeah that was that was a year ago he's
been there oh he was there a year ago he
was there a year ago sure probably over
a mill have come in since then all
hell's breaking loose the state we're in
a constitutional crisis the states are
fighting the federal government he has
dementia like there's a bunch of
problems but he was there a year ago
does he remember he was there a year ago
probably not anyway this is just the
beginning of this and I have to say uh
obviously last week when the santis
dropped out uh I was not thrilled but it
was always and I think I said it on the
show several times it was always partly
like ringing around in my mind like the
states are the things that need to be
empowered maybe the whole federal system
is just too damn screwed up to to do
anything right at this point and I have
to say at this very moment uh on this
National Flor today I'm very glad that
Ronda santis is my Governor if you live
in Texas you should be very happy that
Greg Abbott is your governor and the
lines are being drawn right now and if
you are in a blue state or a blue City
and you're living in one of these
Sanctuary areas and you're watching the
crime get worse and the drugs get worse
and you're watching them fill up
homeless shelters with migrants and all
of these things you should probably
think about your life a little bit and
the choices that you have to
make